Close your eyes and pray for salvation: We’re
returning to the lanky, lethal, lad whose
rampages often result in legendary losses
of life.
It’s SCP-096, the Shy Guy.
Long-time fans of the channel will no doubt
know this anomalous monster like the back
of their hand - after all, we have several
videos on the subject that are definitely
worth checking out sometime - but to get the
full benefit of today’s tale, we’ll do
a quick refresh for any potential newcomers
in the audience.
Let’s start with the basics: The first thing
you’ll probably notice about 096 is its
daunting size and rather unusual bodily proportions.
While mostly humanoid in shape, the Shy Guy
has long, dangling arms that almost reach
the ground.
Its body is thin and hairless, with opaque,
clear white pupil-less eyes and a wide, gaping
mouth.
It’s a truly chilling sight to behold, an
abomination that conjures up nightmares just
to look at it… and we mean that literally,
you don’t want to look at this thing, and
we’ll get to why in a moment.
SCP-096 doesn’t really do much during an
average day.
Usually, this tall, spindly humanoid entity
will spend its downtime just aimlessly pacing
around in its containment cell, and perhaps
occasionally taking a nap.
Pretty relatable, right?
Especially if you’ve been trapped in your
college dorm room during the lockdown.
But, if some unlucky soul should dare to look
at SCP-096 - specifically, its horrible face
- that’s when the monster starts to act
very differently.
Now, someone doesn’t have to be directly
looking at SCP-096 to make this happen, even
glancing at a blurry, distorted photo of it,
or watching security footage of the creature
can have the same deadly result.
You see, the moment the SCP-096’s face is
seen, the wiry monster will know.
When this happens, the creature suffers what
appears to be a psychological meltdown, covering
its face with its huge, claw-like hands and
weeping.
Hence the nickname, Shy Guy.
Utterly inconsolable and suffering from extreme
emotional distress, eventually the creature
will be unable to take it anymore.
Standing up, SCP-096 will then travel towards
whoever dared to look at it, using anomalous
speeds to hunt down the person that saw its
face.
The Foundation has proven that it is unquestionably
impossible for anyone to hide from SCP-096.
Literally nothing can stand in its path as
it tracks down its victim; not walls or locked
doors, even being aboard a boat in the middle
of the ocean, or in a plane in mid-air can
prevent it from finding you.
And when it does find you, it’s not a pleasant
sight.
SCP-096 will kill the person that looked at
it without leaving any detectable trace on
their body.
The monster is impervious to gunfire and all
other forms of conventional weaponry.
It can’t be killed or even so much as harmed.
Even if the Shy Guy is only seen as a tiny
little speck in a photograph, this will be
enough to trigger the creature’s relentless
defense mechanism.
So, because of this, the SCP Foundation’s
only real way to keep the creature safely
locked up is in an airtight steel cube, with
no security cameras or surveillance tools
of any kind.
All members of personnel are reminded that
they are to never, ever look at it.
But what if they could?
What if, somehow, someone was able to neutralize
SCP-096’s anomalous abilities?
Or was resistant to being killed when the
creature inevitably tracked them down?
This is how the tale known as “Picture Perfect”
begins.
“What do you think boys?
Is she a beauty or what?”
Doctor Clef proclaimed to a group of his fellow
high-ranking Foundation researchers.
The group looked in confusion and unease at
what Clef had been referring to, namely a
photograph that he’d just hung up on the
wall of his office.
A photo of what, though?
Well, a four-foot by five-foot picture of
none other than SCP-096, of course.
Naturally, the other researchers shared a
mixture of shock and dismay at what Clef had
just done, as you would if one of your co-workers
hung up a photo of a creature that could kill
you just for looking at that said photo.
We’ve lost a number of staff members from
around the SCP Explained office that exact
same way.
Doctor Clef had long been one of the more
enigmatic and mysterious scientists working
at the Foundation, with the exception of the
elusive and infamous O5 Council.
Alto Clef was formerly an operative for the
Global Occult Coalition, as well as being
known to be a bit of a gun enthusiast and
all-around crazy wildcard.
Clef earned his own brand of infamy for his
rumored practice of brutally “decommissioning”
dangerous SCPs, and you can probably guess
what we mean by that.
He’s the Foundation’s go-to executioner
and a specialist in dealing with reality-bending
anomalies.
Would you expect any less from an ex-GOC?
Joining Clef in his office were the likes
of Doctor Jack Bright, another infamous Foundation
researcher.
Doctor Bright, also known as SCP-963-2, was
assigned to conduct experiments on an anomalous
amulet, SCP-963, which resulted in his death
at the hands of SCP-076, Able.
However, anomalous properties of the amulet
gave Bright the ability to inhabit new bodies
after his death.
Specifically, anyone who also touches the
amulet, which kills the host and allows Bright
to take control of their body.
While technically immortal, Doctor Bright
isn’t exactly stoked about that fact, often
seeking out death and wanting to know exactly
what it feels like.
Also present at the unveiling of Doctor Clef’s
photo of SCP-096 was his friendly rival, Doctor
Kondraki, While usually gruff and anti-social,
Kondraki is an expert in perception-based
anomalies, normally called upon by the Foundation
to photograph SCPs that would otherwise be
invisible or imperceivable.
Doctor Cimmerian, a member of the Foundation’s
Ethics Committee, was also in the room as
Doctor Clef proudly showed off his office’s
latest decoration.
Perhaps the most outwardly strange researcher
in attendance was Kain “Pathos” Crow,
a scientist from the Foundation’s Research
Department who had been transformed into a
Labrador Retriever after an experiment that
needless to say, went a bit awry.
Crow must have been barking up the wrong tree
on that one.
Each of them expressed their reactions differently.
Deeply exasperated, Doctor Cimmerian shook
his head and began to question his recent
decision to stop drinking.
Meanwhile, Doctor Bright looked up at the
painting with a bemused tilting of his head.
He wondered if SCP-096 would come to kill
him, and if it did, would it only do so once,
or would the creature try again and again
each time that Bright inhabited a new body?
Perhaps in an attempt to look away from the
photo, Kain lowered his head and covered his
snout with a paw, while Doctor Kondraki hung
his head in deep disappointment.
The only one among the group that seemed unaffected
by the sight of the SCP-096 photograph was
Doctor Charles Gears, another high-ranking
SCP Foundation scientist.
It was Gears who finally broke the uncomfortable
silence, asking Doctor Clef the one question
that had been on everyone’s minds: why?
Clef excitedly exclaimed that the photo was
meant to be in celebration of SCP-096 finally
having been neutralized, and according to
the scientist, they were free to look at the
creature’s “ugly mug” all they wanted.
The group stared in horror at the gaping mouth,
the screaming expression of the monster that
had killed so many people.
Not one of them shared in Doctor Clef’s
enthusiasm.
Some, like Bright and Gears, simply argued
that the picture was creepy, while others
voiced far greater concerns.
Kain argued that putting up a photo of SCP-096
was in poor taste, that it was massively disrespectful
to all the unwitting victims that the Shy
Guy had killed over the years.
It was also reckless and dangerous, Doctor
Cimmerian added.
It had not yet been a full twenty four hours
since SCP-096’s apparent death, and if the
creature was somehow able to come back to
life, it could easily kill every researcher
in the office.
By showing them this so-called masterpiece,
Clef had put all his co-workers’ lives at
risk.
He shrugged off their concerns of the creature
coming back to life, despite knowing that
was entirely possible.
After all, it wasn’t just anomalies and
SCPs that could defy death, most of the Foundation’s
higher ranked staff were also capable of the
same.
Even some of the researchers in that very
room had died at least once.
Doctor Clef claimed that, should the worst
happen and SCP-096 return to life, they could
simply forget its face with amnestics.
Clef claimed that they were now free of SCP-096’s
anomalous powers, thanks to the creature’s
termination.
But the four men and one dog in his office
with him failed to share his enthusiasm.
The group then began debating why the Foundation
even needed to neutralize SCP-096 in the first
place, when its containment purely hinged
on nobody ever looking at the creature.
“He could be contained by putting a sack
over his head,” Doctor Bright pointed out,
met with murmurs of agreement from the others.
“That’s where you’re wrong Jack.
There could be photos of him from before he
was contained, or someone could get a hold
of the photos we already have of him,” Doctor
Clef argued back.
“If they did something like hack Markiplier’s
Youtube account and put that photo on his
homepage, it’d be game over.
The Shy Guy would breach containment with
millions of dash ones to kill all over the
world, and that kind of rampage would guarantee
he’d have cameras pointed on him 24/7.
Exposure would grow exponentially until the
bastard slaughtered most of civilization.
As far as I'm concerned, he should have been
classified as Keter from the start.”
But Bright argued back, stating that the Foundation
had no real cause to kill SCP-096.
They already had a clear understanding that
the Shy Guy’s anomalous behaviors were only
even triggered by somebody observing it, and
preventing that from happening was pretty
easy.
Killing the creature just seemed excessive,
cruel even.
Cimmerian chimed in again, saying that killing
SCP-096 was something the Global Occult Coalition
would do, and the Foundation still hadn’t
learned all they could about 096.
Could someone survive looking at the creature
if they were in space, or another dimension?
Now no one would ever know.
On top of that, Doctor Gears pointed out that
the Foundation had no clue what SCP-096’s
exact origin was; where the creature had come
from, if it was the only one of its kind or
whether it was part of a species of similar
monsters.
If more beings like the Shy Guy could exist
in the future, they could cause a global catastrophe.
But despite all the points raised by his colleagues,
Doctor Clef didn’t want to hear any of what
they had to say.
“Alright, I hear what you're all saying,
but shut up, you're wrong!
The Shy Guy was a Sword of Damocles dangling
over the whole world, we killed him, and we're
going to celebrate that by doing the one thing
we never could while he was alive; looking
at his face, each and every day, for the rest
of our lives, so that we never forget what
we've won and could have lost…”
The four researchers and the one who had been
turned into a dog all took a moment to consider
Clef’s argument - more courtesy than he
had extended to them.
They all looked up at the haunting, grotesque
face of SCP-096 once more.
As much as they protested the decision to
have the creature killed, each of them secretly
hoped it stayed neutralized, especially now
that Clef was using SCP-096’s photo as an
office decoration.
If the creature ever managed to come back,
anyone that set foot in Clef’s office and
looked at the picture was as good as dead.
Finally, Doctor Kondraki spoke up and threatened
to reassign Clef to one of the worst positions
imaginable: Critiquing first drafts of SCP
reports by junior researchers.
For a moment, Clef thought his rival was bluffing,
but eventually decided it was better to be
safe than sorry.
As the gung-ho Foundation scientist begrudgingly
pulled the photo from his office wall, he
muttered to the group “None of you appreciate
post-modern art.”
Now go check out “SCP-096 Shy Guy ESCAPE
- Incident 096-1-A Containment Breach” and
“SCP-096 - Look at a Picture of Shy Guy
in Space?
The Shy Guy Questions and Theories” for
more on the legendary Shy Guy!